okay so this is another like it's a five
short grunt another five show cradles I
probably go put that together you're
wearing an apron yeah it's very pretty
I'm supposed to sign oh that's right
but we're not going to so this is
another five short graybles it's gonna
be hard to do this just seeing you
alright alright coming your shame a
machine this is awesome all right cover
my shame looking at alright so number 5
shirt graybles um i got chemo phillips
again is back you just couldn't make it
through the review we're in now i got a
look at your semi exposed body
what am i pitching about suburban nights
are so much more that's very very true
goal uh so emo Philips is back as do we
ever get that guy's name you know he
says it I swear but I also don't
remember I was gonna say almost I'm
almost wonder if that's like one of the
glob or grub or something like that
don't remember them no no no I remember
them in the with the Lincoln thing but
eventually say all of them I thought oh
I thought was like wanted to I'm told
four of them oh okay they actually said
oh you're right you're right okay so
well maybe there's missing but anywho so
severe five short grapples but it turns
out we don't want to see that as the
episode dictated we want to see him make
a birdhouse which I love that joke
that's a great joke cuz it's like what
you don't want to see that you instead
wanna see me make a birdhouse and if he
just kept going with well alright do you
know if that'd be funny but the fact of
the camera nods that is hugely funny cuz
it's like whenever you see that's always
representing what the audience really
wanting to see but of course nobody
wants to see him build a birdhouse but
the Caminada that's very very smart I've
never seen a joke done that way with
suggesting what the audience wants when
clearly they don't in that manner I
thought
really funny I wanted to see him build
the birdhouse well there you go you got
the fast port version of that and it's
okay because it comes full circle kind
of man there is nothing technically that
connects all of these at least they
don't tell us what it is
um which kind of pisses me off because I
was looking throughout the whole thing
I'm like you know is this is it that is
it fires an x1 gonna be water is it
gonna be like the the elementors I was
like nope it's just there's the
birdhouse in the background that's it um
again that they've told us but you have
one with Finn and Jake why did you play
with Jake jr. pretending they have a
time machine
Jake probably King his most detail with
the with his shape-shifting uh which I
thought was awesome I love it baby he
creates a hydrant for his big bike like
you don't need the hide anybody goes
through the door behind him it's still
there yeah I thought that was great um
the Ice King putting on the movie for
the Penguins it's like the only thing
really made me laugh was the Jarvey argh
yeah oh yeah the lemongrabs are still
funny I'm still waiting for the episode
where I don't like them but it's like
that's still funny and then cinnamon bun
with the light and dark you know he's
afraid that dark know he's afraid of the
light he goes out rampage and then the
Fox which is great seeing the Fox back
oh I love the idea of his subconscious
him watching his subconscious self write
a letter do it really fun out there
surreal stuff so okay after this episode
aired or after we watched it they just
caught today they don't say well
connects them if there is anything we
were still going we were trying to find
stuff and I'm still kind of convinced
that it has something to do with either
numbers or time and then breathe brought
up really good when she said they have
something to do with age or growing up
because everything you know a cinnamon
bun is acting like a kid the lemongrabs
have their little child in there they're
dealing with Jake jr. who I guess is 30
um the Fox had something reads like
looking at
the old buzzer it's like his
grandfather's place or something like
that and then the Ice King is very much
treating the Penguins like kids as this
adult orienteers this kid oriented blah
blah blah
so i don't know i'm cathleen towards
that but i have no idea if there
actually is anything intended to connect
them um have you read up on this at all
or do you notice anything no I
if there is an intention I don't know I
just thought it was funny but it is
funny just at the end there's the
birdhouse and it's like that's it and
then it's sort of a double fake out cuz
it's like oh you want to see what's
gonna happen the episodes he can gather
oh you just want to see the episode okay
and they never reveal what it is and
yeah I'm just so curious that there
actually was something that this might
be the first episode I want to actually
look up after see cuz I just want to see
if there I too was anything it's like I
said it feels like there's something
with like either age or numbers or
numbers from the UM Korea because it
seemed like I try remember like her
being thirty um I think there was
something about you know vote at first I
thought was like maybe the numbers comes
it was like I thought there was there's
a three in the first one then I thought
there was like a four in the next one uh
uh and and then there's like two
lemongrass up maybe there's some sort
Compton but I couldn't quite put again
there's even the license plate on the
time machine I thought maybe the numbers
are not connected there but I like I
said there's so much champagne in the
episodes just like maybe it says me I'll
wait till the end that way I can put
together easier and of course nothing's
revealed so but like I actually think
the age thing is a growing up thing is
probably closer oh but I don't know it
could just be a huge coincidence - so uh
watch your thoughts on it I liked it
when I first saw it yeah I was like
picking my brain because the first one
you know you can kind of figure out the
second one really throws you for a loop
because it's like oh the five fingers
what are you talking about no it's the
senses or uh the taste yeah that's like
okay so this time I was like actually
paying paying attention like yeah yeah I
was missing half the jokes because I was
paying attention
and this is of course the one where they
don't give it to you and yes kinda
brilliant I mean it's like I almost
think they should do any more just
because they can like I'm sure there's
in our way they can play us and they can
trick us or something but it's like I I
don't know that's like just the perfect
kind of delivery of the first one entry
had something the second had something
but then there was something else yeah
and then this one of course you're just
gonna be so focused cuz they're we
tricked you want and then they going to
give you the answer I'm yelling it's
really clever um the other thing I
really hated and it started pretty much
with this may be the last time was
cinnamon bun hey here's a lil annoying
he's he gradually gets more annoying for
me to the point where I can't stand him
I mean there's not much of him in it but
and again it's everything in this
episode is kind of just like it toned
down a bit because like I said I'm
trying to focus on what's connecting the
ball and it's like maybe he was really
annoying but I was so trying to find
what was connecting them that I didn't
know well like for them for the most
part Cinnabon cinnamon bun has always
been kind of like dim-witted or so
that's okay I'm fine with that but like
this one he just seemed just to override
to you know and just like really just
please quiet it shut up
and I'm sorry I'm on PB side with this
one time to grow the hell up you know
deal with it and in the end what
happened his bitching and moaning and
whining he still gets the goddamn ax but
by the way if the marketing people the
toy people haven't made one of those yet
maybe one of those that would that just
seems like a no-brainer
I mean they look cool I'm even there
they can't be that expensive to make and
it's already got an audience because hey
it was in the episode buy it so I don't
get on that if you haven't yet I did
like how he was there talking in the
beginning and the bird comes up and
steals his cube yeah twice off with it
and then it slowly flows back and then
he blows up I mean he's building the
bird out
well I was gonna say there's something
the one thing that's a little different
in this one is that with that character
the emo Philips character is that
I was actually for the first time
starting to get into where is this and
what is he and like even the way sir
moves like you'll blow up it just sort
of reanimate somewhere else and and even
just everything's kind of floating the
woods calf and there's birds there it's
a it's the first time I'm like you know
what is this guy and where is this I was
actually really questioning because a
lot of these things do sort of come back
or sometimes they're non sequiturs but
it's like how's that you really turn to
question cuz it's like what way did they
show there was a glob and I'm groggy and
all the other stuff you know what what's
this guy's story I was actually really
really curious um and yeah so I said
maybe they'll never review it I don't
know but I like I just like they're
creating an environment more and more
every single time we see him so he
reminds me a lot of you what's a Marvel
character I think The Watcher is yeah
the watcher yeah reminds me a lot of
that
I'm curious James you go back and
rewatch the Lich when they open up the
indictable when they look in the ink i
reading if you will and it shows all the
different dimensions
mm-hmm and it was more attention I'm
curious if his dimension is kind of
floating around somewhere or what not if
okay I want to go back yeah I'm like
really curious about this guy now
something about the what's with the
third one yeah so same about the third
time I'm just like you know who is this
guy
and it's butts the fact they added a
little bit more to they added the burrs
and a thing going around like how he
teleports from layer to another so yeah
now really curious and I'm curious if
they're gonna bring him back or talk
more about it
if they stop it's like okay fair enough
but it's like I I really want to know
like I'm really really intrigued by him
so yeah if you want to bring him back or
anything else if he does come back
that's very welcomed so yes any other
thoughts
we should planned ahead of time and had
like Jack or Bri or Jory like pop up
from down here like Finn hey what was he
doing that way
okay so this is adorable Jory is
off-screen King
it's saying to uh Jacobi and they are
just saying they're like like typical
kids what like proper children sure I
didn't think about it though the fact
that I said we should have had that as a
joke I don't if it happened and now that
we got to work with no we've been bad so
good job jewelry trying to screw
everything up that's my goal in life if
there's anything I forgot I'm sorry I
loved the lemongrab parts with the whole
just everything about it you bought it
what happened at the end uh he ate the
other one right yeah so there only one
lemongrab now we'll have to wait and see
I know he's yelling this is the end I
love that part I almost forgot but
that's my favorite part of this episode
Lemongrab
yeah so there's anything we've learned
um your family sucks
okay yeah I won't argue you guys suck
they're terrified to even talk okay it's
all me back yeah okay